welcome back i'm in the kitchen with
drew crew member and my culinary partner
in crime paular valdez
okay it's that time of the year when
cold weather and the holidays make you
crave comfy food and one of the things
that we've created at the uh kitchenware
line which is expanding into home
is this incredible griddle one of the
things that i love about this product is
you can make entire breakfasts with this
the holidays are coming up if you have
family at the house this can take care
of a lot of people as far as feeding
them because of the surface space but
what can it do on an everyday basis we
came up with the classic grilled cheese
and tomato soup
and tomato soup
all right now we put a twist on the
recipe um for our soup and sandwich
combo
and i'm very excited to show you what
this griddle can do now i'm going to get
right into the sandwich this is a pilar
and i collaboration the two things that
really excite me about this too
is the caramelized onions
and we're using gruyere so it's kind of
like an ode to a french onion soup
that's right it really is
it's just those classic
bistro type of flavors so i'm going to
add the caramelized onions i'm going to
add the gruyere cheese which also just
brings a little bit of that elevation
i give me american crafts every day yeah
every day and any day and i have samples
tomato soup or love um but sometimes
when you'd like to up it for guests or
challenge yourself this is what you add
another element that pilar and i want to
bring to this is please do yourself the
favor
of buttering the sides of your bread
when you see people dropping butter onto
the hot pan
what that does is it actually liquefies
and adds a little bit of a sogginess to
your sandwich but if you take warmer
butter and a palette knife and you
butter the side of your bread before you
put it into your pan
or griddle
you're going to avoid the soggy
liquidness and get more of that crunchy
crispy
brown golden
it's the best tip when you're making any
type of grilled sandwich so i'm going to
do butter all the way like all the way
to the edges because you want to make
sure the whole thing is yes absolutely
is golden brown yes exactly so i'm going
to work on this over here while pilar
takes us through the tomatoes awesome so
what we have on this side actually is a
really simple sheet pan roasted tomato
soup so what these are basically
tomatoes that we tossed in some tomato
paste olive oil shallots garlic and
rosemary salt and pepper and then what
we're going to do is after all your
tomatoes have roasted we're just going
to blend it up and the one tip i like to
give with blending is i actually put the
liquid at the bottom of the blender
first before any of your solids because
basically that is makes it a lot easier
for your machine to go it's gentler on
the motor
it gives it i'm having such a revelation
because i've worked with you so many
times and you've never showed me that
and it's true
sometimes you're like i'm crushing the
bottom to get the top exactly so
hopefully if i did this right um
it should just blend up really really
easily wow the other thing i forgot to
mention and you want to make sure you
scrape all these beautiful bits into
your blender you see the tomato paste so
i'm going to blend this up how are you
doing over there i'm great awesome you
want to puree it until it's
pretty pretty smooth
is there a tip to not over or under
puree so when is it a texture visually i
really like it on the smoother side but
if you like it chunky then don't don't
blend it all the way so that's it that's
all the soup is you pour it into a pot
and you warm it up really gently
and i think i have actually a warmed up
the tv magic one tv magic that's a
little bit warmer i'm actually gonna
plate this up and how are you doing with
your grilled cheese i'm doing great i'm
getting it a little browner we do have
some tv magic over there on the side we
do we do
but i appreciate that
all right all right lovely i have a bowl
of tomato soup for you okay fam
fantastic i'm gonna swap the sandwich
that i'm dying to get in and we just
garnished it with some crispy rosemary
some chili flakes and olive oil all
right now i'm also gonna do this thing
that is what i really love to do
i have to say this is giving me bistro
gourmet restaurant right in your home
this is absolutely stunning
and i can't recommend this more one of
my favorite things is to crack eggs on
it for sunny side up do a little bit of
your veggie or meat sausages
you can do toast you can even cut a hole
in the toast and do egg in the hole
which is one of my favorite things and a
great thing for kids to make you can put
you can put your bacon pancakes on there
pancakes and french toast
there's really nothing this baby can't
do
and i'm really excited to have developed
this product so
thank you pallar visit our website for
this recipe and be sure to grab a copy
of our cookbook rebel homemaker and we
will feature this product from our
beautiful homeline that you can go
directly to shop and buy right now we'll
be right back
[Music]
you